Welcome back to Curious Archive. This video is the
second half of a series exploring the biology and
ecosystems of realistic Pokémon. The Realistic
Pokémon art project was created by the talented
RJ Palmer, aka ‘Arvalis’ I have links below
where you can follow and support his work.
This second round of redesigns features amazing
biological details and an even wider variety
of Pokémon. And please remember the disclaimer
from the first video — these realistic lifeforms
are an exciting speculative exercise, but not an
attempt to somehow ‘improve’ the stylized designs
of the original games. They’re just fun alternate
takes that imagine Pokémon in something closer to
real world anatomy, even if these lifeforms are
more fantastical than what’s likely to appear
in nature. So, let’s jump into part two of
our nature documentary of another world,
and return to the astonishing domain of realistic
Pokémon… Beginning with Gen II starters, we have
Meganium and its pre-evolutions. The designs of
these creatures take inspiration from sauropods,
but also from modern tortoises. And while
tortoises have evolved to eat grasses,
Palmer imagines the long necks of Meganium help
them reach their preferred food of treetop fungi.
And speaking of fungi, the antennae at the end
of Meganium’s nostrils are actually a unique
strain of fungi — which Palmer states the titans
have a symbiotic relationship with — although
the exact purpose is unknown. In contrast, the
flower-like structure on the front of their shell
is not a plant but a brightly colored frill that
mimics flower petals. This might seem strange,
but animals camouflaging themselves as plants
has been documented numerous times in nature:
like insects whose wings have
evolved to resemble leaves.
Up next, we have Typhlosion and its pre-evolutions
— reimagined with greater detail and anatomical
plausibility. In its claws and fur pattern, this
reimagining resembles a cross between some sort of
badger and a sun bear. Palmer imagines Typhlosion
feeds primarily on Combees hives, and the wax
from the hives has a chemical reaction with
Typhlosion saliva to create a flammable substance.
Typhlosions then use their tongues to coat their
quills in this chemical, and then they light them
on fire using specialized flint-like teeth. The
blazing quills are an intimidating display, and
can burn for long periods thanks to Typhlosions’
fire-resistant coat. A really original concept.
And the last starter from the Hoenn region is
Feraligatr and its pre-evolutions, rendered
in all their reptilian glory. Not surprisingly,
Feraligatr is most analogous to earth alligators
or crocodiles. Palmer imagines this lifeform
as a large opportunistic carnivore, lurking in
coastal estuaries and frequently traveling between
salt and fresh water habitats. I’d watch my step
near rivers with these giants around. Moving
beyond Generation II, we have the incredible
desert-dwelling Flygon. Palmer envisions that
this swift aerial lifeform possesses a helium
bladder that helps the large organism achieve
flight. Flygons skim the surface of the desert,
looking out from behind a red transparent
membrane which protects their eyes from the sands.
And on the ground, near some other interesting
desert fauna I’ll let you classify on your own,
we can find a Trapinch and a Vibrava — both
reimagined to look like they could more feasibly
be early stages in a Flygon’s life cycle. In
this alternative world, millions of years ago,
large prehistoric Pokémon stomped across the land,
now known to scientists in the form of fossils.
Taking inspiration from the games, Palmer imagines
recent technology has revived these long extinct
species — like the mighty Tyrantrum and the
lumbering Bastiodon: pictured here locked in
combat in poses reminiscent of classic dinosaur
art. Not surprisingly, Palmer has based his
Tyrantrum off the T-rex, and has reimagined
its beard as a scaly soft-tissue pouch that
could flare out to intimidate rivals. It’s easy to
imagine these creatures living in the primordial
landscape of the Pokémon world 100 million years
ago. It almost makes me want to visit a Pokémon
natural history museum. Another fossil Pokémon you
might find at such a museum is that of Aerodactyl.
Now resurrected as living creatures, the
Aerodactyl are known by Pokémon paleontologists
to be a vibrant shade of purple, and to
possess early proto-feathers on their necks.
Elsewhere in this image, one can spot an Archen
and a Cranidos— further fleshing out the world
of prehistoric Pokémon. Deep in the midst of a
past ice age, the mighty legendary Pokémon Kyurem
reigned supreme. Here, Palmer has redesigned
the stylized armor of the original as more
biological plating. Though Kyurem was a
creature of almost insurmountable power,
the legendary beast Raikou — imagined here as a
Smilodon like ice-age hunter — would sometimes
take the risk and try to ambush this titan. Though
the bite of a Raikou could take out most Pokémon,
Palmer imagines it had less effect on Piloswines:
depicted in this image as ice age megafauna with
coats so thick they provide a natural defense from
the teeth of whatever else might be stalking the
tundra. In modern polar and mountainous biomes,
one might find the elusive Abomasnow — portrayed
as a curious, heavily furred biped that Palmer
imagines were unknown to Pokémon scientists until
the turn of the century — when a specimen
was at last documented. Sharing the frigid
biosphere with these seldom-glimpsed creatures
are the elk-like Pokémon Winter Sawbucks,
and the penguin-like delibird. And another
lifeform in this image is the infamous Mr. Mime,
reimagined as a species somewhere between a frog
and an axolotl. And honestly? I find this redesign
a bit nicer to look at than the original.
Lurking in the cave systems, one can find
Noivern – a species that is a dragon-type in the
games, but that Palmer has reconceptualized as a
creature more closely related to bat Pokémon
like Swoobats. A single Noivern can claim
miles of cave systems as their territory, scaring
off competitors with booming sonic frequencies.
Swoobats are their smaller cousins — and look
much closer to a bat here on earth. And if you
look closely, you can see Joltiks clinging to the
fur of these species. Palmer imagines these small
arachnid Pokémon can create static charges by
nestling into the fur of fluffy Pokémon. Pretty
creative! One massive Pokémon Palmer redesigned is
Onix and its evolution Steelix. Instead of being
made of literal rock, the Onix is depicted as a
massive serpentine lifeform with rock-like scales.
Likewise, a Steelix isn’t fully metallic —
instead, exposure to its natural environment
transforms its scales into shiny, metallic-looking
armor. This process almost reminds me of a
Scaly-foot Snail — a type of marine gastropod
that incorporates iron sulfide into protective
scales on its body — almost like a natural suit
of medieval armor. I could see Steelix perhaps
undergoing a similar process to form its own
protective scales. And holding onto dear life at
the end of these creatures’ tails, you can spy a
Sableye — reimagined not as a ghost, but as a tiny
primate with strange eyes similar to a Tarsier.
Palmer describes this species as attracted to tiny
things, which unfortunately for this Sableye,
included the metallic scales of a Steelix.
Under the waves, the aquatic leviathan Gyarados
takes on the role of apex predator in almost
any aquatic ecosystem they inhabit. This creature
recalls the more biologically feasible design of a
deep-sea Oarfish, which can grow up to 26ft, or 8m
in length — smaller than this version of Gyarados,
but still pretty incredible. Palmer imagines
the marine biologists of this world for decades
didn’t realize the comparatively tiny Magikarp
were early forms of Gyarados, which makes sense.
Nearby, a greater underwater ecosystem flourishes:
including Cloyster, a squad of Tentacool, and a
Relicanth — all looking closer to their real-world
animal influences. Returning to legendries, we
have the awe-inspiring Pokémon Zapdos, an enormous
bird with an incredible electric discharge.
Instead of being an elemental deity, this version
of Zapdos has an extreme capacity for electric
retention — seeking out thunderstorms high in
the atmosphere and gathering electricity like a
living lightning rod. Another electric Pokémon
is Raichu, the evolution of Pikachu that also
looks quite rodent-like. And as you might have
already spotted, this image also contains voltorb
reimagined as a pokeball mimicking armadillo, and
Magnemites and Magnetons as magnetic crabs with
red and blue colored claws. Truly hilarious
designs for some of the most outside-the-box
original Pokémon. Another ancient and seldom seen
legendary is Lugia, redesigned as a lifeform with
more streamlined, aquatic features. One of my
personal favorites, this guardian of the seas
looks like something from the Plesiosauria order —
just even mightier. Near Lugia are some additional
underwater species like Qwilfish and Seadra, all
of which have far more anatomical detail than in
their original designs. In the skies, the immense
legendary Yveltal — redesigned here as a more
avian super-predator – casts a shadow over most
flying types when it comes out of hibernation.
In designing this ancient creature, Palmer took
inspiration from the late Jurassic feathered
dinosaur Yi Qi, an animal whose wings are perhaps
the closest thing nature has ever produced to a
dragon’s. Swooping just out of reach of Yveltal’s
claws are Latios and Latias. With this duo,
Palmer has merged the stylized airplane-like
elements of the original designs with the anatomy
of various real-life bird species — creating more
plausible, but still agile looking lifeforms.
And in the other corner of this image, you can
spot a scalier-looking Salamence, whose wings,
according to Palmer, are formed from membranes
extended over an enlarged set of ribs. This might
seem far-fetched, but real-life gliding lizards
are capable of gliding flight thanks to a set of
wings that are indeed supported by their elongated
ribs, as you can see by this skeleton. And since
we covered Groudon in part one, we have to
touch on its oceanic counterpoint Kyogre — which
looks awe-inspiring in realistic detail. Palmer
imagines this legendary as a leviathan somewhere
between a whale and the absolute largest of marine
reptiles. To catch prey, Kyogre can use a dazzling
bio-luminescent display to lure in smaller
species like Tentacruel. Above the feeding Kyogre,
a swarm of Frillish and Jellicent drift by, their
anatomy much closer to that of an Earth jellyfish.
And if you look closely, you might have spotted
Sharpedo — whose stylized body has been reworked
with a design that takes inspiration from sharks,
of course, but also Ocean Sunfish — a strange and
truncated looking organism. This Sharpedo is going
up against the nautilus-like Omastar — another
prehistoric species that was recently revived.
And as our grand finale, we have the mythical
and legendary Rayquaza, looking truly epic
in realistic detail. This mighty serpent is
exhibiting an unknown display of bioluminescence
as it soars through the air — a sight that would
be intimidating to behold. Exactly how such
a creature is capable of flight is unknown,
and would likely require a variety of specialized
flight organs. Believe it or not, there is a type
of snake called a Paradise Tree Snake that can
glide by leaping off trees, holding its body flat,
and curving in a way which allows it to briefly
coast through the air. Rayquaza, of course,
is taking this to a new level. And there’s
an entire aviary of flying types flocking in
Rayquaza’s shadow — including Pidgeot, Braviary,
and others — all of whom look much more like birds
here on Earth. And with that, we’ve covered
the majority of the Realistic Pokémon project.
If you want to dive even deeper into this
world, there are extra designs – including
some additional legendries — on RJ
Palmer’s site and in his artbooks,
so check the links below if you’re interested.
For now, this is the final part of the series.
Thanks for watching. If you enjoyed this entry,
please lend your support and like, subscribe,
and hit the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things Curious. See you in the next video.